I think we're good to go it's excited to
hear about the state of VB at least a
few mieux
so we're going to talk about the state
of c-sharp and what you might have
missed so we're gonna talk about
features from pretty much all the
versions of c-sharp after the first one
I'll go just quickly run through the
early versions of c-sharp a little bit
of history how the language has changed
and kind of the things that made it what
it is today and then we'll dig into
features and look at some coding
Michelle studio and then if we have time
at the end we'll look at some of the
newer features that might come and might
not come and things that we've hopefully
have wanted to get for a long time but
might not ever get so there's a lot of
things they're gonna cover here so I
hope you had a little bit of snack
before getting in here because this is
gonna go fast so my name is Phillip
Ekberg I love coming back here it's a
great conference and if you have any
questions afterwards just ping me on
Twitter send me an email or just come up
afterwards
all right so c-sharp we're gonna talk
about one of the best programming
languages out there at least in my
opinion and I guess that since you're
rolling here you also like c-sharp
c-sharp is one of those languages that
incorporates features from a lot of
different paradigms we look at financial
programming languages or declarative
programming languages to the imperative
programming languages look at things
like f-sharp Haskell C++ JavaScript Java
all of those different languages bring
features into c-sharp right so the
language teams look at all of those and
they take features and incorporate those
into a a way that that c-sharp developer
would build applications so there's a
lot of different things coming out of
different languages that are really
great but then they take all these
features and make them kind of familiar
to c-sharp developers things like
generics pattern matching and all those
different cool features that make our
applications a lot better so in the
early days c-sharp when c-sharp came out
it was kind of due to the fact that we
got Java I was a Java developer back in
the day and I love working in Java I was
one of those great languages because I
didn't really want to work in C++
so when c-sharp came out being a
Microsoft fanboy I just jumped on the
train right away and then when the first
iteration of c-sharp came out we got
c-sharp 2.0 which introduced generics
I know there's a lot of languages out
there that still don't have generics
it's been a while since I did Java I'd
still don't know if Java has a generics
but it's one of those language features
that make your applications a lot better
to be able were a lot easier to read and
less error-prone right and what's
interesting with generics is that it's
one of those language features that came
out of the research team at Microsoft
the same team that worked on f-sharp and
features for the functional programming
languages
let me get things like partial types
anonymous methods iterators knowable
types etc right so all of all of these
amazing features came into a programming
language that people were already
starting to adopt and then we got even
more features in the third version of
c-sharp we've got things like the
implicitly typed local variables which
is a very long way of saying in the VAR
keyword right
I remember having an interesting
conversation with a co-worker on this
one he tried to convince me that just
because he used the VAR keyword you're
now writing dynamic programming so ICD
you I just D compile the code and prove
that that's not what happens just send
over the il and you kind of prove that
it's not dynamic programming because
dynamic programming in c-sharp didn't
come until the next version and then we
got a whole lot of other features like
auto properties and nonnamous types
extension methods lambda expressions
expression trees all those things build
up the availability of doing language
integrated queries in c-sharp as well as
building things that make our
applications a lot easier to work with
sets of data we got linked to sequel
which was kind of groundbreaking at the
time which then kind of transformed into
link to energy framework and so forth so
we can see here that the two first
iterations of c-sharp introduced a lot
of interesting features but then
something interesting happened when the
fourth version of c-sharp came out we
kind of just got I don't want to say
like minor features because adding
dynamic binding to the language was
probably not a minor task to do but
adding these things here you can see
that there's just a few features added
to the language and adding the dynamic
binding meant that we could do things
like JavaScript and Python and Ruby
programming in runtime in our c-sharp
applications not convinced why you would
do that but you could
if you want to it's a way for us to
bring over scripting into our
applications so if you have a game
written in C C sharp you could for
instance have a scripting engine that
allows you to run JavaScript or Python
in your application but then when we got
the fifth version of c-sharp we got even
less features what's interesting is that
back in 2012 when I started writing my
book on on c-sharp I I was working in
the the CTP of the async and avoid
keywords so this is a long time ago
c-sharp I was added to her roles a long
time ago on adding just a synchron's
methods to a code base that's probably
by then a decade only snow no small
feature right so at this time the c plus
the the c-sharp compiler was written in
c++ and having a 10 year old code base
in c++ is probably not the best thing to
work with because c++ is really hard as
it is but i do imagine that the
engineers of microsoft are pretty smart
so they probably just may be easier to
work with right but we can see here that
the testament that we're getting less
features in each iteration of c-sharp
and that's getting the synchronous
methods is some small tasks tied to the
language so what do you do with a code
base that's really hard to work with in
that feature - well I know that whenever
I have a problem with my code base I
simply just throw it away and rewrite
the application that's da people tell me
that it's a bad idea but it's keeping me
employed so I don't hear so they
introduced a project called Ross Wayne
has everyone in here heard about Roslyn
pretty much everyone I started about
Rosling it's also known as the darknet
compiler platform it's what kind of
compiles the it is what compiles the
c-sharp and VB code right now and what's
interesting with the rosslyn the project
is that they're building the c-sharp
compiler with c-sharp so they're
compiling this new compiler which which
is written in C sharp with the old
c-sharp compiler and nowadays the new
c-sharp compiler is built on the new C's
are profiler on it's it's a it's a it's
interesting but it's it's hard to
explain right what's even more
interesting with the the Rosten compiler
is that it's open source so I remember a
few years ago Matt
Anders at the the c-sharp team was up on
stage and build I believe and he pushed
a button to release this as an
open-source project what that means it's
not like Apple does open-source not
bashing an apple but they do a lot of
open source as well but they do all the
development internally and then just
throw the code in a zip file and their
repository I don't believe that's what
true open source is so what they do here
is that with the Roslin compiler and a
lot of other Microsoft projects there
they are doing all the commits openly
you can follow along with all the
changes to the language you can see here
that there's 91 releases of the
compilers but there's not really 91
releases of Visual Studio right so what
you can do is actually bring down the
code and compile this compiler yourself
using Visual Studio and you can you
replace the compiler that you just built
using the compiler in your environment
if you want to do that if you want to
mess around the new features I wouldn't
really recommend doing that if you're
liking a large team and you want to work
with new features just don't commit the
code that you wrote with the new
features because that's gonna break
everything and of course we can see here
that the community contributes with
issues as well so you can go in and you
can add your proposals to the language
you can go ahead and talk about features
in the language that you like or dislike
or things that doesn't worry for you and
of course you can send pull requests if
you want to do that I've seen a lot of
people actually helping out with the
language and improving c-sharp and VB by
helping out and build these features for
them so it's a great way for for people
to be involved and what's interesting is
that the they have internal design
meetings at Microsoft now I don't work
for Microsoft I just know that they have
control design meetings because they add
the design notes for this on github
after these meetings so they talk about
all the features that they want to add
they have meanings about how they want
to approach the features and what when
I'm not getting to the language and then
they add lis design notes to github so
people can contribute and look at all
these different interesting ideas they
might have around language so these two
in particular are about tuples and
pattern matching which are two great
additions to to c-sharp c-sharp 7 and
they're kind of changed the way that we
build applications especially if you're
coming from a
wrong with Swift development or Kotlin
you'll be very familiar with pattern
matching all right so what are the
proposals that they add was this four
tuples here we can see that they add all
the information about the background for
the future they want to add and anyone
can add one of these proposals so I've
seen the community contribute with
proposals for the language but this also
means that if you can contribute with
features that you want to add to for
instance see sharp that means that
there's no more no more language parody
so if you really love DB for instance
you might not get the features in DB
that you do get in c-sharp so I don't
believe VB still doesn't have pattern
matching for instance it will probably
come in the future but right now they
don't have any language parody anymore
so that was one of the things that was
really important back in the day when
they had the old compilers when they
introduced the feature introduced
something they pretty much did it for
both of the languages
alright so enough just talking about
these features let's look at some of the
particular features that were introduced
as they rewrote the the Rosslyn the
project so the first version of c-sharp
coming out with this new compiler meant
that they could introduce a lot of cool
features in the language and I remember
at the time they wanted to have this
huge amount of features but they had to
cut it down a little bit and add a few
few features of the language but by no
means is this a small amount of features
to add to the language so they started
off fighting using statements for static
members auto property initializers await
inside the catch and final blocks having
done a lot of asynchronous programming
this is kind of a really nice addition
to it and then we got the null
conditional operators and you'll see
later on as well that one of the the
common things that they want to fix in
the language is the mistake of adding
nulls in the first place so we have all
of these ways to work around the fact
that you can do do novel types inside
c-sharp i've got string interpolation
dictionary initializers expression body
members exception filters and the name
of operator so let's have a look at
these features it's kind of a lot of
features to add to a programming
language especially given the fact that
in c-sharp five we pretty much only got
the a' sequence methods so i have
samples from c-sharp 6 onwards to
c-sharp 8 9 10 and we're gonna cover as
many as possible so this here
illustrates a few features attitude the
programming language I'll just increase
the font size a little bit here the
first one is here at the top right so
we're saying using static system but
console that means that we're bringing
everything in from system console that's
static so we kind of find that inside
our scope here which is inside our class
so we can do things like we could say
write line here instead of having to say
console dot write line this is a way for
us to save characters and Scott
Hanselman said something really smart
ones usually says a lot of smart things
but this thing in particular stuck with
me and it said we only have a certain
amount of keystrokes in our lives so we
need to make sure that we don't write
too many keystrokes so with a lot of the
features added to the programming
language we save keystrokes so someone
else make sure that they write the
keystrokes for us I think that's pretty
good so we can call things like write
write line and read line and we get
everything from from system console in
here which is pretty great and of course
if we were to add a method in here
called write line it would use that
instead because that's the closest one
it would find super smart and then we
also have this thing called string
interpolation which is this little
dollar sign here at the start of the
string instead of having to write string
dot format I can now use string
interpolation to say whenever you find
these curly braces this here is gonna be
a code block where you can evaluate that
thing and get the string representation
out of that alright so I can do I can do
whatever I want in here I could call a
method I could have a variable in here
and that would give the the spring
representation for that variable and I'm
using the name of operator here which is
simple way for us to say I want to get
the name for the program so this here
would compile down to two looking like
this here the reason that we want to use
the name of operator is because if you
refactor the application now it wouldn't
find the the usage of the program inside
my string here so if you work with
logging and you have all of that inside
your application which you should have
then this here's a really nice feature
tab so the next feature we briefly I
talked about what's the outer properties
and now with the c-sharp c-sharp six you
can do
auto property initializers which means
that we can do through read-only auto
properties so this here is say property
where I initialize the value of name to
Philip and then inside a constructor I
could change this value but if I try to
do that in my main method down here it's
gonna give me a compilation error saying
that role this is in fact a read-only
auto property or a read-only property so
you can't really change that there's a
nice enough feature to have and then we
have their weights inside catch and
finally blocks imagine that you have an
asynchronous operation you call a
website or you talk to your database or
you write something to disk and then
that fails then you catch that exception
and you might want to clean up after
yourself and then you can do that inside
the catch block and then in the final
block you might want to dispatch the
message message onto a queue and they
say that the operation is completed or
that it failed and then we got an old
conditional operators this is where it
becomes a little bit more interesting so
this classical person here the person
has an address an address has a street a
simple simple enough example if we
scrolled up here to the top initialize
an array of people and then with the
first one initialized as just with a
name Philip and then the second person
is not initialized at all and then I
call his method which is called process
people which doesn't know about my
collection right so this here is a
simple for loop for each loop it's going
to go through all my my people and
you'll see here what it's doing instead
of saying well I want you to give me the
name of the person but then I have this
little question mark here saying well if
person is null this entire expression
will be evaluated to no so it doesn't go
ahead and get give us a no reference
exception if we remove this question
mark here this would cause a no
reference exception and then we could
say that these defaults to unknown and
then of course we do the same thing with
the address we say well if person is not
no going to give me the address if the
address is not no they give me the
street and if any of those things inside
this this expression here is null then
just give me no idea as a default
message and this works for pretty much
anything right so this works for a race
as well so I'm initializing an array
here called other people it's null from
the start and then I can say well if the
other people are array is not no go
ahead and give me the first index and if
that is not no good and give me the name
so that's pretty nifty this is all due
to the fact that they did a mistake of
adding nulls in the first place imagine
a world without Knowles that would be
great so I think someone calculated how
much no reference exception has cost the
world I don't know how you do that but
yeah so the next feature is expression
body members again this is to save
characters so we have this two string
here at the bottom normally when you do
a a two string you would say return
whatever you want to returning here but
now with the expression body members
instead I can replace this here so I can
save actually they say it's the same
amount of characters so in this case
it's actually useless right so instead
of having two about two curly braces I
do in the error say actually I do now
don't brought the return keyword here so
to save a bit of keywords keystrokes so
this here you can do with anything you
can say you can call a method here you
can use string interpolation you can do
whatever crazy things you want to hear
and I think this is really nice I do
this a lot if I override them if they
override something from an interface or
an absolute class and I just need to
introduce from some simple
implementation for it the last feature
added to c-sharp six is exception
filters exception filters is one of
those great things that we kind of wish
that we had for a long time so imagine
in this case here I'm going to call a
website I'm gonna call google.com and
I'm on a slow Network when I used to
live in Australia could joke that I just
use a syllable network because it's crap
there but since we're in Europe
everything works pretty flawlessly here
we're for G so this will probably never
happen but in the case of a timeout we
were on a really slow gsm network we're
gonna timeout so we're saying here catch
the web exception only when the status
off that exception is timeout so I can
access the this variable inside my my
one Clause here
so what happens is that it doesn't in
fact go into this here unless this
pattern matches the exception and the
same goes for this other one here I'm
saying well if we have flight mode turn
on if this race running on a phone
inside a stammering application for
instance we can say well when they're
the web exception is in fact a name or
solution failed we want to catch this
here previously what you had to do is
that you have to catch the web exception
and then do an if block inside the catch
right but that would catch all the
different web exceptions if the
exception that we get inside our try
block does not match these two it's
going to be the weave wreath row and
back to the caller so that's pretty good
so that's all of the features that were
added to c-sharp six kind of a lot of
features added to a language just right
after they introduced the rosslyn
compilers but that kind of shows the the
power and the the importance of
rewriting the compiler and sometimes it
is better to just throw out your old
code and rewrite everything so the next
version that they released on the
rosslyn compilers is the c-sharp 7.0
language version and they talked for a
long time about doing things with with
tuples and deconstruction and pattern
matching and all of these interesting
features that that are rounding out all
of your other programming languages but
they haven't been available to do with
the old compiler because it was really
hard to add feature to that so now in
c-sharp 7 we get tuples and
deconstruction and we'll talk about the
way that they're differ from the
original tuples that you can use in the
framework we've got pattern matching
which is a really nice addition is
anyone in here doing coughlin or swift
just one excellent so we'll have a look
at pattern matching it's one of those
kind of groundbreaking things that when
you start to use that in your
applications and when you understand
like why you want to use it it's really
making your code a lot more readable and
then they got some smaller features as
well like digit separators and binary
literals that I don't think I would ever
use local functions is interesting and
referee turns and out improvements so
let's have a look at those features as
well so in c-sharp 7 the first have to
talk about the the fact that we've got
tuples so tuples
can be seen as a way for us to pretty
much return multiple types without
creating an type for that or create a
local variable that holds more than more
than one variable without having to
create a class for struct for it so this
here we could for instance say well I
want to get the point this point here
returns two variables and this here
represents the topple that's good that's
going to be created for us I could of
course add more things that could add
inset here as well and int a int B but
this is starting to get ridiculous so it
would probably create type instead but
for from less primers I would probably
like that so now get point here returns
this topple that I'd like constructor at
the bottom so this here will take the
100 and match that into the variable X
and then take 200 match that into the
variable Y and then when we use this if
we go down to our main method down here
there's a lot of different ways that we
can use this but let's just call point
first to see what we get we do bar piece
equal to get point and now you'll see
here that I can do p dot and we get x
and y there at the bottom so this here
gives us a strong the type way of saying
well give me these two these two
properties or these two fields and then
we can introduce something called
deconstruction so now that we have the
tupple we want different ways for us to
put that into different boxes so we can
say one way of deconstructing the topple
is to say well I want to put these
values into the new X&Y variable that
have hearings inside my my scope in here
what's really interesting is what it's
doing is that it's not matching based on
the naming it's matching based on where
it is inside the topple so if you want
to be a really nasty developer you do
this right and then you have a problem
and I really interesting bogging our
application now what happens here is
that I can say points again point X and
point of y and I can even do point to
topple and this converts it back to an
traditional top pole where we get would
get the item one in item two which we've
been able to use back in the day as well
so most of these features are just
purely compiler magic they don't rely on
any runtime changes at all so that's
great and then another way to
deconstruct this is to say well I want
to get the point into these two new
local variables called x 1 and x and y 2
and then another way is to say I want to
cut down the characters and don't have
to say which type it is twice so you can
say var X 2 + vara Y - all right so
that's tuples and then we have pattern
matching now pattern matching is a way
for us to to match on it on a particular
pattern which could be a class it could
be a way that a class is represented but
that's a feature that we will talk more
about in C sharp 8 when we talk about
how they improve pattern matching but
now the basic pattern matching that was
introduced in c-sharp 7 we can look at
this this class here for triangle and
the rectangle which both inherits from
shape they have some different
properties of course and then we'll
scroll up here to the top and we'll see
that I'm introducing this shape here in
this case it's a triangle I'm doing a
switch switch case here on my shape and
in the case of this being a triangle so
this is the pattern right so it's it's
matching that's against that the type is
a triangle and then it's capturing the
triangle as a local variable of T which
is then available inside just this block
here so I don't have to do any type
casting myself it just grabs this here
when it's the correct type and the same
goes for my rectangle so I would be able
to use all the the properties and types
on my my class here right so I would be
able to ABC so this is kind of the
basics off pattern matching but this is
the first version that they added in
c-sharp 7 it's getting more interesting
in c-sharp 8 as well as a little bit
more confusing and then local functions
I've seen a few examples of that being
used but I don't know if I would ever
use it myself first here at the top
you'll see using the binary literals so
someone probably thought that well since
we're saving keystrokes somewhere else
let's introduce like
by our literals so instead of having to
just write the the number 16 we can now
do this is a binary literal instead I
don't know if you do bit shifting this
is probably a really nifty and then you
have the digit separators as well lookey
underscores just don't do it when it's
really confusing like I did here
and then I have the local functions here
at the bottom where I say well I want to
calculate this thing here of X and then
we don't know what the internal things
doing here it's actually a Fibonacci
calculation error in internal internally
as a local function some minor feature
said it's new language but they still
pretty interesting so if you're doing a
lot of high-performance memory
programming which you will probably not
do in c-sharp I guess but if you want to
do that if you do any games or or such
in c-sharp you might like that they are
doing some improvements to a references
and and memory memory things with the
language so in this case here I have
this local method which returns a
reference and this is a reference to a
value type now what's interesting here
is I'm saying well this thing here
allows me to grab the element is at a
particular position inside my array so
I'm passing both the array and then the
position it simply returns a reference
to that position in the array it's
really just a nasty way of doing what
I'm doing here in the comment right but
anyway so what this is doing here is
it's just giving me a reference to this
which means that when I get the
reference which I'm doing here I'm
saying well give me the the second index
right so the the first the first item
then I can change the value of that
since it's a reference so this is
exactly the same as doing this which is
a bit confusing but if you run this here
it should actually change the value so
the first one is 2 and then it changed
that to 10 so improvements either to the
ref returns it's really interesting if
you didn't high-performance applications
and then the the last feature added
seven it's a way that they improve the
out keyword if you're doing a lot of
interrupts with older api's in Windows
for instance this is probably a god-sent
I've used a few api's where you require
to you out out parameter and I've always
disliked the fact that you have to
whenever there is using out you have to
specify everything at the the line above
and then send that into the method like
this here now with c-sharp seven they
can simply say out VAR X and that just
creates that variable for you whatever
it's neither right makes sense so not as
much as cutting down the characters but
making your code more readable and
understandable so that's all the
features added to c-sharp seven now
since they released the compilers it's
an open source project and they since
they're doing a lot of rapid development
and they don't want to wait for Visual
Studio to be released what they can do
now is introduce point releases which
means that they can introduce c-sharp
7.1 or they can do c-sharp seven point
two three four or five and how many
point releases they want right they can
release this a say and then update with
a the visual studio update without
having to worry about jumping on the
train of a major release official studio
so the first point release that they
ever did was seven point one and that
introduced things like the async main
method so if you're doing a console
application or if you're you have
something that's running as a scheduled
task in Windows you can now leverage
asynchronous operations inside your main
method of the application without having
to do nasty things like wrapping it a
tasket run and then forcing it to block
and then we have the default expression
which is a way for us to save some
characters again it's gonna infer the
topple names with pattern matching with
generics just starting to improve the
pattern matching and then represent
please let's have a look at a few of
these features
now the biggest one here is probably the
the fact that we can do a sink main
methods maybe not a lot of people right
console applications but if you're doing
scheduled tasks in Windows doing it with
console apps it's really nice so don't
have to do a service for instance so you
can see her that I'm marking my main
method as async and instead of being a
static void it's now async task of main
and we can stay awake you were just like
we could in another it seems like a
synchronous application and then you
also see the default keyword here at the
bottom instead of having to write
default off shape so traditionally you
would write write it like this right so
now instead of having to to write shape
here at the end you can now move it over
to the the start of the expression
instead becomes nice when you do this
with the construction as well because
you don't have to specify the type over
and over again all right so then the
other one that I want to talk about is
just infer topple names it's an
improvement to tuples
so in this case here I'm creating a
temple like we saw earlier so I've got
this this new point here which creates a
class called point which has an x and y
property and then I'm creating a couple
out of those two values so normally what
happens here is that you would get
something like this here you would get
toppled item 1 in toppled on item 2
but with C sharp 7.1 it's now inferring
the names based off on those properties
or fields so we can do tupple dot X and
toppled are why it's a nice addition it
could of course had I've said like this
right just to be totally confusing let
me get rid of that otherwise I'll have a
bug later on okay so that's seven point
one not a lot of features added to seven
point run right so but still a few of
those additions just to prove that they
can do a point release so we're all seen
we they can do a lot of crazy things
like just adding features as they like
now in 7.2 they probably felt a little
warm warmer in their clothes so what
they did was that introduced a lot of
more interesting features again
something that's only interesting for
someone that's - maybe high-performance
applications were working with Interop
with older API so you can do read-only
ref reps and in parameters which is a
read-only way for you to passing
something to a as a reference non
trailing named arguments stack Alec with
span of T
that's an interesting feature that we're
gonna look at private protected for the
people that don't know if they want a
private or protected you can now use
both of them at the same time I don't
know why but yep
someone once is a feature and I guess
it's easy to add it to language and then
we have the conditional conditional ref
operator and the digit separator after
the basic specifier so I don't know like
it seems like people are using those
digit separators because they did an
improvement for it
so just because I don't use the features
doesn't mean that no one else does so
the first one is the ref read-only and
in parameters so we have this method
here at the top what's interesting here
is that it's specifying that it takes a
reference of an integer as the first
parameter and then we have this in
parameter which is really a reference
but it's a read-only reference so if I
try to change this here it wouldn't work
so why would you use a reference because
it's faster you don't have to copy the
value and then here at the the return
type it's a reference but it's a real
only reference because it wouldn't
really make any sense right to say in
here that would be really weird and
since the out keyword is already used I
couldn't use that either right so
somebody read-only wrap or refereed only
makes sense and then here we can see
that how it's being used
i initialize two local variables and
then I have a call compute here which I
know returns our reference and then the
crazy things here is that I have to say
that this is a referee don't leave or
upset
because what happens if I do this
if I do this it's still gonna work but
now it's gonna copy the value into a new
variable locally so that's totally
confusing when I set up the dam I'm like
oh this is gonna work and then I try to
run it with changing the value at the
bottom I'm like what so that's how you
have to do it and then we have an
example here of non trailing name
arguments so imagine that you have 50 or
something input parameters and you use
the first ones and then you want to have
named one of them and then the use of
rest which is for that override you just
have to use the naming ones you don't
have to specify the naming for all of
them so that's pretty nifty so in this
case here I just have to actually
specify the first one which is X is
called : or FX and then I don't have to
set it for the second one and in this
case here in is actually redundant you
can't specify in here but you don't have
to because it's gonna infer that for you
some super nifty all right so does
anyone heard of the span so if you heard
of span so span is a way for us to
represent a chunk of memory and in this
case here I'm just allocating an integer
an array of integer on the stack by
using stack a lock so this is one of the
language features that I was introducing
c-sharp 7.2 now I'm using the span of of
interior's been of t to say well I want
to to represent this chunk of memory
some way without having to copy the
array every time I work with it so what
I can do here is I can say well I want
to get a slice of this array here so
we're gonna get a slice from the item 52
and then we're gonna get 10 items and
this year we'll give us a chunk of that
memory just like two pointers but it's a
nicer representation so it doesn't copy
the array for you so it's a truly high
performant way of just grabbing a copy
of that chunk of data or grabbing a
reference to that chunk of data okay so
seven-point-three was one of those
versions that introduced Apple equality
stack alec initializers improved generic
just improve generic constraints so a
point release would not a lot of
features but still they won't probably
want to release something before they
just do a big bang release with c-sharp
eight which is going to introduce a
whole lot of interesting features so
again let's have a quick look at the
code here and the reason I don't live
code is because it's going to take
forever so in this case here we're just
doing topple equality and what's
interesting with this is just as we
talked about earlier it's comparing
based off the where it is in the topple
so we have a hundred and two hundred
with those positions and then we can
compare that to a new topple here at the
bottom which is not the same one that we
returned right so it's going to compare
the values and tuples so if we run this
here it's gonna say true hopefully
because the the tuples are equal and
then we got the generic constraints if
you're working a lot with generic
programming this is really nice so you
can see here that this class called
ticket here has two generic parameters
the t data and t type and i can say well
I want the the T data which is the first
one to be my I ticket data of the type I
ticket data and then I want the T type
to be an enum and then when I initialize
this here I can say where all I want the
ticket to be a ticket data and valid
ticket types and that just just works so
if you're doing a lot of generic
programming this is really nice and then
another just improvement to stack
allocation you can do that with object
initialization as well so if you do a
lot of high performance apps and you
want everything on the stack and then
you can do this as well right so that's
pretty much everything up until the
point of where we are now so that's all
of the language features added from
c-sharp pretty much one to seven
three that's a lot of features attitude
the programming language so you probably
think that well c-sharp feels like it's
one of those languages that's that's now
complete but since a lot of other
programming languages keep living on as
well and you get new new ways of
building apps and you want to build more
for mobility or you have IOT we want in
our language that kind of adapts to
different situations so what's happening
with c-sharp now is that they're still
doing everything in github and you can
go ahead and go to there's this language
features status patient github and I'm
really proud because my face is up there
it's a great contribution to the year to
the platform I just fixed a spelling
mistake
well everything counts right so this
here just illustrates all the different
features that they want to add into the
to the language and then you can go to
another place which is the the c-sharp
lang repository and get up and this
illustrates all the the c-sharp eight
candidates so these are all the
champions that they want to add to the
language you have everything in here
from parents of span of T to read-only
members and structs and a lot of
interesting things that they want to add
to the language everything like record
types and so forth and we'll have a look
at a few of these features in just a
moment but well it's interesting is that
they're they just add all these features
and you can see even here I don't know
if you in the back and see that but like
there's a lot of comments on all of
these different suggestions and issues
on github because there's a lot of
people that are involved in making this
easier programming language better and
one of the commonalities between these
different versions of c-sharp and what
they try to add to the language is the
fact that we want to avoid no reference
exceptions so again they want to fix the
mistake Bob that they did by adding
notes in the language but how do we do
that well maybe by the point of c-sharp
10 I bet that's gonna be the next
version after 8 because they seem to be
skipping 9 for her things I don't know I
recognize you call it X and not 10 that
would be a better name for it and then
maybe XS an X or
maybe not maybe maybe not so these are
all the features that they were going to
add to to the next version of c-sharp
which could be C sharp 8 HR 9 10 11 so
forth it's gonna be a lot
so getting ranges that's probably coming
in c-sharp a acing screams and
enumerables record types target typing
expressions
sorry type new expressions probably
require a runtime change so most of the
features added to c-sharp up until now I
haven't really required a runtime change
except things like the the dynamic
bindings the default and deconstruction
generic attributes caller expression
attributes and hands using so they're
doing like a pattern based thing so
imagine that you can look at a class and
you just know the purpose so instead of
having to implement eye disposable as
long as you have to dispose method on
your class you can use it in the using
block that would be right so I hope they
do that for more things I would like to
see this so if your class implements an
interface without explicitly
implementing the interface I would like
to be able to see that class being
passed into a method that requires that
interface does that make sense I think
go allows you to do that and I think
that's a great thing but I'm not sure
they're going that way all right so
they're doing default interface methods
this means that we can now introduce
default methods on interfaces so you
don't have to require the the person
that pulls down your interface to
implement the method you can provide it
with a default implementation inside the
interface and I'll talk more about why
that's nasty later on Noble reference
type so we can now say that my
application does not allow you to do the
nulls anymore and no policy assignment
switch expressions declaration
expressions dictionary literals type
classes and then is equal and or it's
equal say that ten times fast assignment
operators static local functions parents
of span of T we don't with struct
members negated condition your
statements no condition or weight and
more we're not gonna have time to look
at all of these but we'll have a look at
a few of them but this just proves that
there's so many features being added to
the line
even though that we have everything from
generics to link to pattern matching to
all the ways that we work with
asynchronous operations there's still a
whole lot of things that we want to add
to the language right so there's still a
lot of things that we could add to the
language so when do we reckon that
c-sharp and it's gonna be out well
according to github it's two percent
complete and it's January 1st 2080 so
this is a way for them to secure their
jobs I reckon so
now joking aside this is probably to be
a part of not all of those features but
c-sharp 8 is gonna be a part of Visual
Studio 2019 which is what I've been
using here when doing my demos and let's
jump into looking at some of the the
features of c-sharp 8 so I don't have
all of them but I have a few features
here for c-sharp 8 the first one I want
to look at is ranges now ranges is one
of those interesting features that you
could potentially do a lot of cool
things with again especially to work
with large collections of data so what
you can do here and what I'm doing here
is that I'm setting up this span of T
that we talked about earlier I'm just
going to increase this a little bit I'm
setting up this span of interior using
the stack outlook I'm just using the
objects and this is initialization for
that allocation of my stack and then I'm
using data duct slice to say I want a
part of this data how about you start
from from the index 5 and then you give
me everything until the the
next-to-the-last right so if we run this
it should give me 6 to 9 right 6 7 8 9
yeah it says it all right so we can do a
lot of cool things here we could we
could use different patterns with the
ranges I don't know all of them by hand
but you can say that you want everything
from from the last one until they start
and you could do a lot of cool things
using this pattern here and again this
here doesn't create a new version off
the it doesn't copy the array when a
view data duct slice here just gives me
a representation off that so it's kind
of two point
right so it doesn't copy all the data
over so this is a super fast it's like
it's super fast
I guess super fast it depends on what
kind of thing you compared to but in
this case here we have some recursive
patterns for for changes in the pattern
matching if we scroll down to the bottom
let's scroll down even more you see here
that I have a point here at the bottom
and I've introduced something called a
deconstruct that's a way to deconstruct
the object so we can say that when this
is deconstructed it creates the the x
and y fields and the same goes for the
rectangle of introduced that here as
well and this is kind of just to help me
with the the pattern matcher which will
look at at what in one second and then
we have the same four four triangle and
then have the shape which has a point
now the recursive patterns it's a way
for us to do a few things first of all
we can say well when it's a triangle I
also want to check something else so
when it's this type then recursively
check another thing you can check
another thing and you can check another
thing right so using the new switch
expression here as well which is also a
new language feature so I'm saying
return a string which does a up here so
return based off the shape run this
switch statement when it's a triangle
capture that as a local variable of T
and when the sides are not equal
where all I want to return that string
and I'm using this expression here and
then I'm accusing and then I can use the
deconstruction to say well what inside
triangle and we have this side a B and C
and when there's a point but I don't
care if the point X is set so this is a
bit confusing but that just shows you
what you can do with these recursive
patterns so you can first check the type
for instance and you can check whatever
the deconstruction gives you so if these
were reference types for instance we
could check if their null and this
underscoring means that I don't care
about the value
okay and then I can have this default
expression here at the bottom so when
there's no when doesn't match is either
the triangle rectangle it just returns
whatever right so we like T the
improvements with the pattern matching
now know the reference types look at
that we have the the question mark again
the famous question mark shows up and
here we're saying well I want a string
here where this is in fact allowed to be
null so if I remove this question mark
here now I've set up in my my project
here so this is a c-sharp a feature I've
gone in here and I've said knowable
context option enabled that means that I
cannot have nulls in my application well
I can't have no if I really want to but
I'll see you later
so in this case here it's now it's going
to say yes quickly here to say well you
have a null nullable property called
name which is undefined so they want you
to set this into constructor so now it's
it's nice to not be in c-sharp eight
that it's telling you that you should
probably initialize the value hopefully
in c-sharp time it's gonna just slap you
in the fingers and give you a compiler
error but you can set it up set that up
yourself now what we can do here is that
we'll leave that as a knowable one and
then you see here that I have this
method called print' here which takes a
person and it knows that well person
here could potentially be no no right
because it's a reference so how do we
fix that sorry well we can promise that
person is not going to be null or we
could say that that if it's null it's
not going to do anything but then it's
going to say well that's not good still
gonna say that we have a problem right
possible dereference of no reference
what you can also do is say that well
this person here is allowed to be null
see this get rid of it gets rid of the
errors there we go so now we're saying
well personally or could be null if it's
if it's not know going even
it's not they'll go ahead and give me
the length so now we don't have these
errors anymore but you can also do all
you can do all sorts of crazy things in
here you could for instance say that
well let's do this I could say that you
promised that person is not going to be
null in this case right so that's and
you could even do that for if we do this
I promise that this person isn't gonna
be novel well don't do that so you have
the bang here to say that well I promise
that this valleys not going to be null
so if you introduce these features in
your language like you're not gonna have
a problem right it's just there to help
you find the null reference exceptions
and I believe that John skeet an example
of how he introduced this in in no time
where he showed how he found some some
potential bugs or just introduced two
features to help him reduce the problems
all right so before we end let's just go
through a few of the other interesting
features that they might be adding to
the language I'll share these slides
later on but you have the links at the
bottom to the proposal so you can go
ahead and read them on your own later on
so this is all available in github as
well so they won't to add async streams
which is a way for us to use the away
keyword with the for each loop so
imagine that you want to a synchronously
get each item in this for each loop well
you can do that you can now do that and
this is then decompiled down to just a
simple way for us to saying well while
we await the move next async method here
just go ahead and do whatever you want
on your UI thread right so you could
have written this code yourself but it's
nice to get first-class citizens in the
language to help us with this and then I
talked to just briefly about the default
interface method so imagine in this case
here we have this interface called I
authenticate async now I was I said I
authenticate async sorry has this in the
first version we have this user versus a
user and then allows us to authenticate
we implement this interface and then
someone releases a second version but in
this case here we introduced
default implementation and I'm using the
the expression body member here to do
that now what happens is that we can
even call this inside our method and it
would use in our application and we
would use that implementation what's
interesting with this is that the first
thing that I thought of is that well
this introduces multiple inheritance
it's kind of the same thing right except
that we don't have the access to
variable society we don't have the
instance of a class right that's the
only difference so you don't have two
classes that inherit from each other but
in this case here working at
implementations from different places so
it's interesting it helps people that
builds these API sand interfaces so you
don't have a problem each time you
operate a package from you get it's a
nice addition then who knows Ricker
types might show up in c-sharp ten or
eleven it's one of those features that
they talked about adding in c-sharp six
but for some reason it's really hard to
implement and you'll see why in a second
so imagine in this case here we have
this triangle of shape it has all these
different sides and a constructor that
requires it to set these these values
then with with record types we could
simply say well I want this triangle it
requires have the side a B and C and
even here some shape and what happens
with the compilers and it generates all
this interesting code here so for
instance it implements the I credible it
sets the values in the constructor it
introduces two equals which checks the
values and out the references it gives
us this with things so the idea is that
it's immutable so you have to get a new
triangle in order for you to change
about leaves and then the D constructor
at the bottom now where it gets tricky
is with inheritance so if you have one
record type inheriting from another
record it would be really hard to
construct this code here my solution
would be just to don't allow inheritance
but maybe we will get something really
smart in the next version of c-sharp
and then we might be getting something
called negated conditions if statements
and they've talked about this for a long
time as well
I believe this showed up way back as
well when c-sharp 7 came out so we can
do this now all right so we can say well
if not shape is a triangle but that's
kind of nasty way of saying the the
negative negated condition right so we
could say well if shape is not a
triangle we could say if not or we could
say unless the shape is a triangle so
these are all the different options I
reckon I like the last one but I still
don't like the the fact that they
introduced a new keyword I really don't
like the second one maybe if shape is
not a triangle is the best one to notice
and then they're doing improvements to
declaration expressions as well so I ran
into this recently where I had to write
some code like this and actually tried
to do this here at the bottom but it
didn't work so I have to put the the
initialization of your variable or the
declaration of the variable before you
set the value in the while loop in check
in so this is going to be a nice
addition as well so I reckoned that like
all of the features that came in c-sharp
one two seven as well as the features
from you know c-sharp aid and onwards
are things that make the programming
language really powerful one the idea is
that all these features not only make
our applications like more that were
less error-prone but you know they also
make it easier for us to build
applications and maintain them some
people tend to say that well adding more
features to the language means that you
you might get applications that look
totally different but I think they've
made a pretty good job that to make it
so that when a c-sharp developer builds
an application it looks like a c-sharp
application doesn't look like a PHP or
Java or costing application I think
that's really a great way to to build on
top of this language so just to wrap
this up I think that with these
additions to c-sharp I think it's
becoming I need a better programming
language and we'll see improvements to
pattern matching in all the ways that
you can avoid nulls in the future and
even with all the older features in
c-sharp even if you haven't used the
async and up with keywords I think that
having these features available is a
really great addition to the language
and just makes it easier for us to build
better
applications right thank you so much
we're coming don't forget to vote on
your way out and I hope to see you next
year as well